i did a ceremony on a native american  reservation in  uh san diego a couple of last month you  know i've i've  i've  done uh mushroom ceremonies but never  like a huge dose all right and this guy  said in our tradition we take a pretty  big dose he said we take 15 15 mushrooms  and so i was like  okay when in rome let's do it you know  and so but it was like a ceremony like  we were in the wombash in the circle and  there was a fire pit and like  it was profound it was like  deep you know like i connected to  something ancient yes it was  deep  you know  and  you know and i it just  connected me to like there's so much  more  going on in the world  like i mean like other dimensions that  we have the ability to access okay and i  think that's what these substances are  doing they're they're opening up our  sensitivity to these other dimensions